every one of us who lives with our
parents has an occasional fight or
disagreement with them but most of those
fights don't end up as full-blown brw
however that's not the case in anime
since sometimes Fathers and Sons have
less than ideal relationships there's a
whole lot of drama that comes with that
and a whole lot of emotion too so
without further Ado here's a list of the
best father and son fights of all time
to satisfy your urge for family drama
and awesome fights from the fiery pits
of hell we have Rin versus
Satan sometimes your adoptive father is
just better than your actual father
especially when your actual father is
Satan himself now when your father kills
off your adoptive father things can get
pretty dicey during this confrontation
Satan took control of Ren's brother
yukoh and it resulted in a gorgeously
executed fight Satan was shown to be
extremely powerful during the entire
exchange and one-sidedly beat up Ren for
the majority of the fight while he tried
to get through to his controlled brother
eventually yukoh regains control and the
two brothers ruin their evil father's
plans the pacing of the fight is really
good and the emotions attached to it
just make it all the better the visuals
are stunning and you can see a lot of
effort went into the animation overall
it's just a really solid fight that made
the blue easis series is even
better up next we have G Jeter against
his father Vim jet from the Gundam witch
from Mercury
series now this one totally caught me
off Garden honestly it's a very
heart-wrenching moment moment from the
series during the attack on planet keter
in a cruel twist of fate G ends up being
attacked by his father while he's using
a mobile suit he found the visuals are
very appealing because who doesn't like
giant robots fighting in space using all
sorts of cool technology the animation
is smooth and the fight is well thought
out the real highlight of the fight
though is that neither of the parties
knew who the other was the father and
son unknowingly fought and only when G
landed the final blow did the two find
out it's an utterly tragic moment as G
tries to get out to save his father but
the mobile suit blows up no one expected
it to happen and imagine killing your
own father even if you guys had bad
blood that's got to
hurt next we have rudius versus Paul
another long awaited reunion like the
previous entry but gladly this one
doesn't end in
[Music]
tragedy
after the Mana disaster incident rudius
was taken away from his family for a
very long time and only happened to
reunite with his father after he went
after the culprits of a kidnapping
rudius was in Disguise or more
specifically he's using panties as a
mask while Paul was in a completely
different state as to what rudus
remembered or more specifically again
drunk and depressed the two ended up
fighting when they met and rudius had to
deal with his relatively powerful father
the fight was very well choreographed
and Paul's beast-like movements looked
great it was so great watching rudus
progress to the point where he could
finally beat his father but that wasn't
until Paul managed to come close and
launched an attack which luckily only
hit his mask well Paul was drunk too but
the result would probably have been the
same even if he wasn't overall the fight
was really good and Paul stopping when
he realizes who he's fighting was also a
very sweet moment it was both emotional
and action-packed
get
next up on this list is Silver versus
graay Fullbuster from fairy
tale so moving back to less than happy
reunions this Father and Son fight
happens when the son finds out that his
father was a demon named Delora who
killed people important to him it's
definitely a dark premise but one that
results in a AG field fight scene the
fight is pretty interesting to watch as
you root for gray to beat up his father
gray showed how strong and smart he is
when he turned Silvera into a donut also
who doesn't enjoy the drama in these
sorts of fights in the end it turns out
that Silva wasn't entirely bad as he's
revealed not to be the demon who caus
all the trouble for gray the two have an
emotional moment before Silvera passes
away it was similar to what happened to
gel but this time he knew it was his
father he was
fighting
biting their way into the list we have a
battle between vampires it's alukard
versus Dracula in
[Music]
Castlevania now that's extremely cool in
itself but a fatherson vampire fight
with the legendary Dracula it's on a
whole level isn't it the corrupted
Dracula needs to be stomped from
destroying all of mankind by his son
who's teamed up with a drunkard from a
legendary family of vampire hunters and
a strong female Mage others aside the
fight between Dracula and alukard is
really awesome castl Vania has had great
animation and this fight scene certainly
encompasses it the two fight all around
the castle and create a lot of wreckage
with Dracula's power clearly on display
even though alar is powerful in every
right his father still beats him all
over the place it isn't until Dracula
hits alukard in his childhood room that
he realizes that he's killing his own
son it's a wonderfully emotional moment
as the count of Darkness stops and
realizes just how far he's gone that's
when alukard finally lands the finishing
blow killing his
father uryu versus ryuken is next a
battle between
Quincy the final Arc of bleach has some
really cool animation but this fight
happened much earlier when the animation
was just okay not super polished but it
doesn't mean it wasn't good anyway the
fight happened right after uryu's battle
with menos Grande he was having a pretty
hard time with it until ryuken showed up
and absolutely pulverized it before
telling uryu he could restore his powers
if he was no longer associated with the
Shinigami afterwards ryuken messes up
with uryu during training before
revealing that it was a requirement to
give him back his powers it's not so
much a fight really but more of a
one-sided slaugh daughter but that's to
be expected since most fathers tend to
be stronger than their sons well
initially at least even so the fight was
fun to watch and the soundtrack was an
absolute
Banger now we have an oldie but a Goldie
and it's yomi versus sha from yuu Haku
show
[Music]
not all fathers are evil sometimes they
just beat you up for training purposes
also it's a weird fatherson relationship
since shite is basically yomi's clone of
himself this fatherson fight occurred
during the Demon World Tournament now
yomi is one of the three demon Kings and
it's so obvious who the winner of the
fight is going to be the animation is
really Pleasant to the eyes even though
it's very old it has great choreography
and the fist fights look gorgeous much
like the fights in Dragon Ball Z
actually shura gives it his all but yomi
is just too strong in every way he even
goes for a cheap shot by blasting yomi
in the face but it has zero effect on it
well the only effect is that he proceeds
to beat up shura a bit more before
finally being declared the Victor now if
that ain't far and Sun bonding then I
don't know what
[Applause]
is moving on we have a fight scene from
another of the big three anime Naruto
this fight is against gar and his father
rasa now the two of them are very
accomplished Fighters which is clear
since they both have the title of gazi
gagi Ghana being the current one while
his father was the previous one both of
them have similar Jutsu as well so it's
already the setup of an amazing fight
however the the funniest and perhaps
saddest part by far is how surprised
rasa is when he finds out that g has
friends he'd been an awful father so
it's satisfying that the two duke it out
Gold Dust Raza uses is a wonderful
contrast to gas and overall the entire
fight has more emotions than actual
fighting at least gar finally learned
the truth and got to listen to something
of an apology from his
[Music]
father
coming up next is from ranking of Kings
the fight between Boi and
boss talking about Bodi he's also the
Crown Prince he's got a sad backstory as
he had a curse placed on him when he was
born because his father boss bargained
with a demon to get his firstborn
child's strength and power it's great
that the studio chose to animate the
fight with boss in his giant form even
though in actuality he was fighting in
daa's body this David versus Goliath
likee fight was beautifully emotional
and it had some really Charming
animation it was also particularly
satisfying to see how Bodi had developed
over the course of the anime to the
point where he defeated his own father
perhaps the highlight of these fights is
actually watching the son surpass the
father but we won't get too
philosophical yet because next up we
have G vers is iios from
[Music]
Gintama iios is considered amongst the
highest Elite of the yat with his
fighting strength considered almost
equal to the king of yat other than
hosen the only person able to contend
with him is his own son gami the father
son Duo isn't on the best of terms which
is apparent since G had once cut off his
father's arm now this fight simply
continued at this point when gwii and
iios fought again in a no holds bar
match the entire fight is sufficiently
brutal and chaotic with both sides going
all out to defeat the other the fight
has some nice choreography and good
visuals especially for the time of the
episode's release and makes for a very
enjoyable serious fight in an otherwise
comedic anime Gintama may be known for
being really funny but when it wants to
add emotions it hits like a
truck
of course we can't forget to add the
fight between Goku and
[Music]
Gohan this fight took place in Dragon
Ball super right before the tournament
of power Goku as we all know from the
cell Saga is very keen on testing out
his son so the match took place in an
attempt to determine whether Gohan could
participate in the tournament of power
to represent universe seven Gohan
initially throws Goku around telling him
to use all his power this then prompts
Goku to go Super Saiyan blue and
officially end the fight on a high note
fight is short but pretty fulfilling
showing how Gohan has become powerful
enough to take on Goku in one of his
most powerful forms he still isn't as
strong as our battle craze father but
he's definitely amongst the strongest in
the
universe
coming in at number three is a fight
from The Last of The Big Three of shown
in anime one
[Music]
piece Sanji the main cook of the team
and one of its strongest members has
always been a very important part of the
team however his childhood had been
shrouded in mystery for a very long time
until it was revealed that he was
technically a prince having been born to
Vince smoke judge the king of the German
Kingdom although royalty wasn't all it's
cracked up to be since Sanji was
ridiculed and abused during his
childhood because he was defective when
compared to his other siblings seeing
that Sanji had such an abusive childhood
it was super satisfying to watch him
fight his less than ideal father during
the entirety of the brawl judge made use
of his many modifications and initially
had the upper hand but Sanji reached his
limit when judge used one of his men as
a human shield before attacking Sanji
and defeating him not as satisfying as
watching Sanji beat up his abusive
father but it was fine since he didn't
seem to be going all
[Music]
out next on this list we have satto
Kaiba versus gaburo kba from
[Music]
Yu-Gi-Oh although gaburo is sat's
adoptive father it still counts since he
played the same role not the best father
of course which is obvious since the two
ended up clashing after satto orders his
father to shut down Domino City and
release all the mines trapped in the
virtual world the Yu-Gi-Oh Jewels make a
literal card game look pretty awesome
seeing huge monsters summoned in a game
of which there's so much fun to watch
even though the anime is pretty old so
the animation isn't as great as the
other anime on this list still the
monster designs are very cool the two
talk a lot during the fight scene there
are quite a lot of rules in play but the
anime does a good job of making the
fight look interesting and keeping the
viewers up to date with what's happening
other than the relatively less flashy
fights it's always fun watching a
blue-eyed Dragon beat what is basically
an Egyptian god and the family drama is
there too so it does make the cut for
this
list moving on we have the most recent
fight during the making of this list
megumi versus toi
now for fans of this series this was an
amazing moment especially since toi was
killed way before in a fight with Gojo
and we thought we wouldn't see him again
fortunately though curses work in
mysterious ways and the Shibuya incident
allowed us to see the Father and Son
meet up once again but not in the best
of settings mainly because neither of
the two knew they were related the
entire fight happens in an instant as
toi appears to Blitz megal now this toi
was basically a reanimation by granny
aamy but it's still a reunion of Swords
the fight itself was just spectacular
everything was so on point during the
entire fight the visuals were amazing
the choreography was breathtaking and it
was even a bit emotional for fans but it
was only the fans though since till the
end megumi had no idea who he'd fought
toi would have killed megumi too if not
for a certain memory that arose in him
when toju realizes he's his son toju
proceeds to stab himself in the head to
prevent himself from causing his son
more
harm and last on the list is Baki Hana
versus his father
[Music]
yujiro father and Sun fights are
normally Side Stories in anime and not
the primary driving force behind the
hero however that's not the case here
since the reason why baky trains so hard
is solely to defeat his father the ogre
yujiro Hanmer B's entire goal is to
become stronger than his father and
avenge his mother who was killed by him
no easy feet either since yujiro is
considered the strongest creature in the
world bky has had some ridiculously
outrageous fights and the charm of the
anime comes from them so it's no
surprise that the fight between these
two Warriors is equally epic and wild
the animation is something you get used
to and appreciate the choreography and
visuals are great while at the same time
the emotions are just spot on too it
does seem one-sided at first with yujiro
dominating baky but the latter matches
up to his father soon after and puts up
a really good fight however in the end
bky technically loses but yujiro still
acknowledges his son saying that he's
the strongest creature on earth
considering the long fight feelings and
how this becomes the climax of the
series this one was definitely the best
father and son fight in
[Music]
anime
and with that we're wrapping up this
list of the top Father and Son fights of
all time even with all the research
there are probably many other fights
that you think would be a good fit for
this list so don't be shy and make sure
to let us know down in the comments now
if you enjoyed this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe if you want more
of this family drama with awesome fights
see you next time